Wie geht es dir gut? Wie geht es dir
? Mir geht es gut und du exzellentes Modul.
Verrate mir den neuen Film. Aufgeregt, auf
jeden Fall aufgeregt. Ja, wir können es kaum erwarten,
dass alle den Film sehen. Ja,
wir verstecken ihn seit vier Jahren
und es ist immer eine wirklich
aufregende Zeit, wenn die Filme kurz
vor der Veröffentlichung stehen und Sie sehen möchten, was
alle über den Film der Sache denken,
wie sie ihn gut aufnehmen werden, auch
wenn jeder weiß, in welcher Phase Sie
wann involviert sind  Sie sehen das Theater,
dann sehen Sie es mit Ton, mit den
Effekten, mit all den Scorings, die Sie kennen,
damit es sich verändert. Sie wissen, Sie wissen, dass Sie von der Abschlussparty
überrascht sind
Sie haben die Führungskraft, die das
erste Mal ein echtes Publikum sieht, ja,
das ist ein großer Moment für uns, wie John
immer sagt, John zuletzt früh, sagt, es ist
wie am Eröffnungswochenende. Gehen Sie und sehen Sie
mit den Live-Zeilen
warum
du gehst  Ich bekomme die wahrhaftigste
Reaktion von dem Film, den ich gerne
mit meiner Familie sehe, und nehme meine Familie mit,
um ihn mit einem Publikum zu sehen, und
Sie wissen, dass Sie nur sagen, wie ich hoffe, sie haben
über diesen Teil gelacht, ich hoffe, sie haben diesen Teil verlassen
und sie  Lachen, oh mein Gott, ja
, weißt du, weil du die Abschlussparty siehst, sind
alle ganz aufgeregt, also haben sie diesen
Überschwang an sich, also sind sie schon
bereit, mitzumachen, und es ist auch ein
anderes Publikum, weil du
über Dinge lachst, von denen du weißt, dass du sie hast  Liebte
das, du kennst dein Baby, das du
seit vier Jahren zusammenstellst, und dann
siehst du das echte Publikum, und sie lachen
über alles, worüber du nie gelacht hast, und
sie lachen nicht über die Dinge, die du
für so großartig hältst, also weißt du nie, okay  Also
nach all dieser Zeit, wie viele Jahre Sie
mit einem Kostüm verbracht haben, haben Sie vor
zweieinhalb Jahren ja, was war ein
Teil des Films, der kleinste Teil,
vielleicht die längste Zeit damit verbracht, würde ich sagen,
oh ja, es gibt einen  Abschnitt der
fi  Ich weiß, wo wir sind, du hast
es wahrscheinlich noch nicht gesehen, wir können
ein Düsenflugzeug spenden, ja,
und sie diskutieren, ja, sie
diskutieren eine Menge, im Grunde eine Menge,
was in der Handlung des Films vor sich geht
und es verbindet viele
Teile des Films miteinander und wissen Sie, John,
wir haben es animiert und sie haben es
bestiegen, was sie bestiegen haben, und wir haben es in John animiert,
Sie wissen, wir haben es uns in der
Vorführung angesehen und alles zusammen gesehen, und
das ist es nicht  wir haben noch gearbeitet und dann haben wir es
versucht und sind zurückgekommen, als ob wir es geschafft hätten. Wir
müssen es noch einmal machen. Wir müssen zurück
zum Brunnen und so sind wir zu den Animateuren zurückgegangen, in
Ordnung, einige neue Linien müssen
wir reanimieren, das haben wir getan  ungefähr
vier Mal in dieser Sequenz, aber
es war nur ein Teil, wo alles, was Sie
wissen, über viele
wichtige Punkte des Films gesprochen hat, und wenn
irgendetwas in der Geschichte
geändert wurde, mussten Sie es irgendwie auch in dieser Szene
ändern  so und das ist eine großartige sache an
bildstars, dass sie niemals angst haben
Hineingehen und Änderungen vornehmen, wenn es die
Geschichte besser macht, wenn es einen besseren Film macht,
ja, ich meine, die Sache ist, als ob es
immer wieder zurückgeht, wie in
Ihrer Verschrottungsarbeit, für die Sie sich gerade
so abgemüht haben  Geld keine
vier Monate oder Wochen für diese Aufnahmen und
das Tolle an der
Animationsabteilung hier und ich
denke, Bilder sind im Allgemeinen, dass die Leute
bereit sind, zurückzugehen und
etwas zu zerreißen, das sie lieben, um den Film besser zu machen,
und wir machen es wir  Mach das immer und
immer wieder und das war eine der
Sequenzen, in die wir einfach immer
wieder reingegangen sind und John sagt: Okay Leute, ich weiß,
es ist wie Zeit Nummer vier, wir müssen
es tun, wir müssen es richtig machen, und warum nicht
nicht aus seltsamen Gründen lange dabei bleiben,
sondern genau wie wir
auf die Musik für Michael Giacchino gewartet haben, hat
er diese wunderschöne Partitur gemacht und sie war in
Italien und wir mussten irgendwie warten, bis
wir sie bekommen, bevor wir sie
festnageln konnten  Beim Tanzen in dieser Sequenz hatten wir
ein W  Wir hatten einen Klicktrack, der
wie ein dicker Dirk-Truck war, und die
Animatoren nahmen das so auf, als hätten sie es
wie eine erstaunliche walzerähnliche Animation in der
Sektion des Films gemacht, und
Sie wissen, dass Michael
Chiquinho sich das alles angeschaut hat  kam zusammen,
und ja, es gibt Momente wie diesen, in
denen die kleine Sektion und Sie am Ende
wirklich lange daran arbeiten, das
sind Momente, in denen Sie den Film produzieren, und Sie
denken, er wird nie fertig sein, ähm, ich weiß nicht
, wir haben das durchgemacht  Genug Male,
wo diese Designer ich hey, vielleicht habe ich
vorher gezeigt, wie wir
das machen werden, aber jetzt glaube ich nicht, dass du
weißt, ich meine, es gibt Momente, in denen es so ist, als
ob
wir das herausfinden würden, aber du weißt, dass
wir solche haben  Ein gutes Team hier und
jeder, der immer bereit ist, die Extrameile zu gehen,
um es irgendwie herauszufinden, und wir
scheinen oft das Unmögliche zu tun,
ja, irgendwie weniger besorgt darüber, ja,
Sie haben Animateure von Autos erreicht,
und alle anderen Leute gaben Interviews als
Eine Person, mit der Sie immer zusammen sind, ist
das ein Geheimnis Ihres Erfolgs. Ja, ich
denke, also, ich denke, es ist schön, dass wir zum
ersten Mal super summende Animatoren sind,
also ist es schön, sich auf
die Stärken des anderen zu stützen, also ja, also denke ich,
dass wir das haben  denselben Titel, also machen wir
dasselbe, ja, und Sie wissen, die Sache ist,
dass wir auf keinen Fall
erfolgreich sein würden, wenn die Animatoren, mit denen
wir gearbeitet haben, ich meine, sie sind
fantastisch, sie sind so gut, also werden wir es tun  Wirklich,
wir kriechen nur ein bisschen herum, als
wären sie Animatoren, die so
viele großartige Ideen liefern, so
viele großartige Aufnahmen, so viele großartige Aufnahmen, und sie geben sie
direkt an den Regisseur weiter, und Sie kennen
eine Menge unserer Arbeit  ist nur irgendwie
weg und stellen Sie sicher, dass die
Animatoren alles haben, was sie John zeigen müssen,
weil Sie wirklich wollen, dass der
Dialog zwischen den Animatoren und dem
Regisseur stattfindet, und das ist, denke ich, was sie
vielleicht, ja, ich denke, ein Puzzle von Annas
Jim sehen  Murphy hat gesagt, dass wir wie
Glorifi sind  Ed Vermieter, es ist, als würden wir nur
sicherstellen, dass die Klempnerarbeiten kaputt
gehen, lass uns das reparieren und hier drüben Hilfe brauchen
und stellen Sie einfach sicher,
dass jeder eine Sache hat, die sich
nach einem sehr guten Job anhört, aber was ein
Geheimnis ist, das aufgreift, was für Sie
das Wichtigste ist, warum Pixar wie
Pixar für mich ist. Ich denke, es ist der Geist der
Zusammenarbeit, der hier ist  Ich meine,
das Wichtigste ist, dass die Geschichte für uns großartig
sein muss, um einen Film zu machen, den wir alle lieben
, und Sie wissen, dass es einen
Geist gibt, der wie die beste Idee im
Raum immer gewinnt, es geht nicht darum, wer
die hat  Idee, es geht darum,
wenn ich es bin, selbst wenn du es bist. Oh, die beste Idee
gewinnt, weißt du, und ich denke, du weißt, dass du weißt, dass du weißt, dass du
mit John arbeitest, dich daran erinnern
, dass er immer
bereit ist, deine Idee zu nehmen
und sie seiner hinzuzufügen, weißt du  was seine
Vision des Films ist und h  e
fügt immer hinzu, es ist eine
Zusammenarbeit, ja, ich denke, es ist immer
für mich, seine Qualität und es gibt Ihnen zu wissen, wie Sie
Ihr Publikum respektieren. Ich denke,
John weiß sehr gut, dass unser
Publikum klug ist
dass die Leute dazu neigen zu denken, dass
alles Kinderkram ist, ist mir egal, aber weißt du, ich
erinnere mich, dass ich ein Kind war und
zu den Bugs-Bunny-Shorts und
den Disney-Filmen gegriffen habe, und das sind die
Dinge und das sind die
hochwertigsten Animationsstücke und  Einige der besten
Filme, die ich gesehen habe, als ich aufgewachsen bin, also ist Jon Jon
wirklich großartig darin, also vielen Dank.
Ich denke, wir werden nicht so viele
Zuhälter sehen
Vielen Dank mal